welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and is the high evolutionary actually
gone I mean he for sure tries to act
like a ruthless and uncaring one in
Guardians 3 but could he seriously be
considered a God in the MCU well I think
so but let's dive into why I think so
together speculation Nation but first
guys we have the most amazing Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 shirts look at this
one like I actually came up with the
idea for this shirt before I saw uh any
of the Guardians promo so I'm so excited
that like me and James are on the same
way like buy a shirt or two or three or
five thousand nerd ride that shot baby
now here's why I believe the high
evolutionary from guardians 3 is
technically an MCU God first and
foremost ain't no another thing for a
second that the high evolutionary was a
God if he didn't possess a crucial trait
that most if not all gods have a crazy
long life well if you don't get stabbed
like Friga or while he has Guardians
that hella killed in Thor Ragnarok
anyway from what we can glean in
Guardians 3 the high evolutionary is a
lot older than he looks on the surface
while confronting Rocket Raccoon in the
movie The High evolutionary tells rocket
that over the hundreds of years that his
experimentations have been going on he
had never met a mind that he had made
quite like rockets and while most people
would assume he was giving rocket a
compliment he most certainly was not
that dude was pissed that a broken
rodent could achieve something with
little effort that he the long-lived
high evolutionary could not figure out
and when he chats with a young rocket
about the music that is playing around
them he does mention that the song they
are listening to was made around 5 000
years prior suggesting that he was
around the first time that that
particular piece came across his ear I
honestly do have a hunch that is the
very power of his suit that is the
source of his long life I definitely
recommend that you check out this video
that I made a few weeks ago explaining
immortality in the MCU because there
appears to be a common energetic link
between all the super old raisins in the
universe it's the color blue one of the
biggest factors that I believe gives the
high evolutionary official God status is
the way he closely monitors the
evolution of multiple planets and
species across the cosmos like before
the high evolutionary the only beings
that we knew of that were responsible
for doing this were both the asgardians
and the celestials I mean I would
mention the gods of omnipotent City and
they would all stop boning each other
long enough to give a damn about their
suffering followers like command Zeus
you can stop skirt shopping for two
seconds to give Gore a glass of water
but anyways we know from both eternals
and the Thor movies that both all father
Odin and erisham the judge were closely
involved with ensuring the preservation
of human evolution directly getting
involved if anything gets in the way of
their Divine plans for Humanity's
Evolution like you know when Odin fought
the frost Giants to protect Earth or
when air Jim got involved when he
discovered that the eternals messed up
his Grand Evolution plan by turning
Tiamat into marble but speaking of the
celestials the high evolutionary seems
to be taking a lot of his Godly cues
from them more so than any of the other
humanoid gods that the Mortal beings
worship listen guys we made this video
with the help of geology and with their
help you can make your skin healthier
than ever geology is a 19-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
their products are built around just a
handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades just a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
geology's co-wash and deodorant are
great and they use them all the time but
right now they're running a special
offer for a skin care sampler pack and
geology skincare stuff is in a league of
its own geology's line of skin care
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging there has
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars100 to get 100 off
your personalized 30-day skin care
sample set that is right everybody 100
off all you have to do cover the 495 for
shipping and on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer up to 50 off and additional skin
hair and body product of your choice
when you add it to your trial click the
link in the description or go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started remember how
the high evolutionary kept all of the
data of his species patents in those
disgusting looking flesh balls flesh
balls that glowed with yellow neurons
when plugged in this reminds me a lot of
the world Forge from the Eternal
specifically when erishim showed Cersei
that they were storing all of the
eternals memories Within These Crystal
shelves with glowing yellow neurons in
them I feel like James Gunn purposely
made orgo corpse data storage that
disgusting just so the high evolutionary
could mirror the celestial
evolutionary's ways of keeping their
experimental data organized and also
much like the celestials the high
evolutionary does not seem to be all
that interested in not causing planetary
genocide if their evolutionary
experiments start producing undesired
results the high illusionary definitely
shares the celestial blatant disregard
for lower life forms hardcore but it
isn't all destruction of course because
like grumpy Gamora says the high
evolutionary is actually responsible for
the presence of a ton of MCU alien races
and planets in the cosmos we learned
from Adam warlocks and idesha's
involvement in the movie that the high
evolutionary was apparently directly
responsible for the creation of all the
golden jerk holes of The Sovereign but
grumpy Gamora also mentions that the
high evolutionary also created the
zoronian and Anime races amongst many
others not much about the zironians have
been established in the MCU but we do
know that they are a race of pale skin
freaks with no lips in the comics the
zironians were actually all sort of
orange looking with one Cyclops looking
eye with the exception of the most
notable zoronian of all Randolph who
gained five eyes after mutating himself
into a super soldier capable of fighting
The Incredible Hulk I freaking love
random man like I made a whole video
about him years ago like he's so great I
freaking love him but the high
evolutionary never created the zironians
in the comics but he did however creates
the anime who have yet to appear in the
MCU technically but in the comics the
anime are merely a group of five
humanoid animals who act as the high
evolutionaries special team of muscle
and murder and they thought the scarred
spider one time but apparently the anime
had their own damn planet in the MCU so
count on Earth might not have been the
only safe haven for intelligent animals
I mean the high evolutionary did mention
a new Colony awaiting him and all of his
workers if he survived the Guardians in
the movie so chances are there might be
multiple planets out there that have the
high evolutionaries anime and finally a
major trait of the high evolutionary
that gives him major God status in my
opinion is his ability to create super
powered beings through his evolutionary
Medline because at the very end of
volume 3 we learned that one of the
evolutionaries child prisoners was none
other than phylavel a character most
famous for becoming the hero Quasar in
the Marvel Comics after serving some
time as Captain Marvel and she is also
of course famous for her relationship
with her fellow hero moon dragon a
character that I believe was secretly
introduced in 4-4 as love like I made a
whole video about that like love is
straight up moon dragon you should
definitely check that video out if you
are confused as to why philavel is a
child in the MCU right now but anyways
philavel appears to have the ability to
generate energy from her hands sort of
like Captain Marvel or even Star-Lord
and Guardians 2. a gift seemingly given
to her by the high evolutionaries
experiments and if you think about it
Star-Lord himself is the result of a
Celestial experiment via ego in Captain
Marvel's ability to absorb blue
Tesseract dark energy is likely tied to
the celestials messing around at human
development over thousands of years but
yeah that is why I seriously do believe
the high evolutionary technically counts
as a god figure in the MCU he is
purposely trying to be a humanoid
Celestial but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at Master retainment on
Twitter if you guys want to see me tweet
some weird and really fun theories
but most importantly you could follow
new rockstars where we are on the social
medias and of course don't forget to hit
up nerd riot.shop you can pick up a new
Guardians 3 shirt they're all amazing
and you'll look amazing in them so go to
the right restaurant shop today but yeah
thanks again for watching this video and
I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign